a lot of us don't trust ourselves
because we haven't spent much time being
ourselves
sure so even this the most empowering
part of
adapting something is over time not
overnight
but rebuilding that trust that you
actually you can find your way through
this and it might not look like
the way your friend is doing this the
work but you're doing it and you're
trusting the way you're doing the work
because i get so many questions and i
get it people asking me
exactly how what are the one two three
write the directions down
and i can't because my direction for
whatever it is that we're talking about
might not be exactly what your direction
should be
for you so the beautiful part is
learning
sure to connect with yourself and
learning
your way through whatever it is the
heart and the healing
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
on the show today is nicola pera she
goes by the holistic psychologist on
instagram just this woman has such
wisdom and experience and knowledge
about
things that we face and so um so i've
been following her for a long time
and you know she's very good at
explaining
and inspiring you to deepen the
relationship with yourself
to learn about yourself to understand
why you react to certain things why
certain people would react to you then
of course too
and how to understand how to navigate
from this really present place when it
comes to
life and the challenges whether it be a
relationship
perhaps it's a family dynamic which she
talks a lot about because that's very
present in her life
but with nicole it's all about the self
and so she has this beautiful program
that she does
um which is a future self journaling and
so for anybody that follows her on
instagram you'll see a ton of that in
her stories and with her followers
it's a way to create the life that you
really want and of course that resonates
with me deeply because that's
in the intro i really hope that you take
as much as i did from this episode she
is a really really wise woman so
enjoy the show nicole you you just seem
to hit it on the head
whenever you post something it's like
yeah
and i you have a super power you realize
that
i appreciate you saying that um i'm
hearing hearing more and more of that
but i think part of it is
the relatability you know when i talk
about my story i think there's a lot of
i joke and i say i'm the universal the
universal human in a lot of ways
so some of it is just me talking about
my story that i think is pretty
universally
relatable to a lot of us a lot of it is
hanging out in the comments i'm really
into my community
that we've built over at the instagram
page so i'm really engaged and when i
say hang out my comments i
that's that's like a kind of a data
collection site for me so i mean
literally in the comments
quite literally just being in my
comments seeing people how people how
the collective is responding to whatever
i'm posting
that helps continue to direct me because
while like i was saying earlier some of
my healing journey
is a bit universal not all of it is so i
can see the holes and i can see where
people are struggling maybe in ways that
i didn't struggle
right by what's coming out in the
comments and then i'll use that
as the platform to continue to create
more i was actually going
to ask you so i have a pulse kind of all
the while so i know me
i know the people that i you know are in
my personal life and what they struggled
with with their healing journeys or like
my clients as well were a really great
learning ground for me but i have a
pulse on the collective
smarter the size of the account so
there's so much of the time that when
you start to get really popular as you
have your instagram account has like 1.7
million followers and you've had it for
like a year and a half which is
amazing which just shows how much it
resonates with people
um but you hear a lot of people like oh
i don't read the comments you know
because there's so many opinions out
there
but it is but you're finding the value
in it
and the pulse and the heartbeat of where
people are at cause i was going to ask
you
what drives your content yeah yeah just
noticing where people are at observing i
mean i did
i did individual client work for quite
some time both in
i call it like the old the old modality
of the talk therapy
so i had a sense i think of the places
and the ways people were stuck
that's kind of i break my my
professional life into two separate
journeys so
i think the journey when i was just
doing the talk therapy myself included i
mean i've been in talk therapy i've been
on medication
that i think gave me a large awareness
and that's that was a really big impetus
for why
i shifted my work in general because i
kept coming
up against stock and stuckness and even
with myself like i
felt like i was insightful i maybe knew
what i had to do differently
to get the results in my life that i
wanted whatever they may or may not be
but yet i couldn't and then years of
seeing individual clients coming in for
talk therapy very similar to the methods
that i was using
that was a theme everyone was stuck even
the most insightful
you know people we would have great
sessions where you know we would
have an insight and we would so get
something maybe even know we're
connected to in our past
for this client come up with a game plan
and then yet
i would come in the next week with a
report if that was all great but my life
still looks the same
i'm still in my negative habits and my
pattern so that was a really big kind of
wake up point for me
in general so when you say talk therapy
so everybody understands
um explain what you mean by talk therapy
yeah all of the different
facets of time yeah for sure so i mean
historically and this is the way that i
was trained so
you are historically let me back up even
further the model
of mental illness um i like to profess a
model of mental wellness because i do
believe that we can all achieve
wellness but old paradigm and asking for
what you want not what you don't want
yeah i don't want illness so let's not
just so much empowerment that i think
this shift can happen but i think that
there's two
two worlds there's the old world where
it was very much that deficit model that
like genetic if i have that chip or if i
don't have that chip
i do have a deficit and that might be a
physical illness
a mental illness you know whatever it is
that i'm struggling with
there's a cause that can't be changed so
we're having a conversation about
management
right how do i give myself a life that's
within these
already decided upon parameters whatever
my genes are ending
you know right exactly so i can only get
so well and i can only
you know get so sick so that's and i
just didn't believe that to be true but
with that
said the models then were talk therapy
where you can come in
you get a great therapist and i'm by no
means i still think that there's a place
and a need
to have supportive individuals whether
or not they're in the form of a
therapist or a best friend so
this when i talk about this i'm not
talking down
on talk therapy or support i think
that's necessary
but in the old model our options to
manage right this deficit whatever it
was
was talking so you get a therapist you
come in every week
and you explore you explore your
feelings some of it is cbt you change
your thoughts et cetera and then the
other option was
medication so because you have this
genetic deficit
we can boost you know or enhance the
therapy with medication and those two
often go hand in hand so that's
as a therapist that's what i was doing
you have a degree in psychology right i
have a degree in clinical psychology so
and everything that i was taught along
the way
was leading me down that path of you
have and this is what i wanted i mean i
should mention that too i wanted to be a
therapist i wanted to hang my shingle i
wanted to have a practice i love people
i love understanding them
i love you know having connections with
them so that's
what i was very much interested in doing
i got my phd in clinical psychology
which would allow me to do that
and the methods that we were taught we
were not taught anything of the
medication that's in the psychiatry
realm
but we were taught all the ways that we
could provide talk therapy in that
supportive environment
yeah so flat fast forward i have the
practice
week after week i'm clocking hours in my
personal life i too am struggling with
anxiety
for as long as i can remember i'm on the
medication
i was in pretty intensive therapy at
different points along the way so i was
doing the same thing past tense
right past tense past tense that i was
that i was offering to to clients and
then it took
my own what i call my own dark night of
the soul my own
you know physical spiritual emotional
meltdown breakdown
that first and foremost scared me um i
thought because of some of the physical
symptoms that i was having
i thought that i had something
physically wrong with me so
in as we all love to do we dive on the
research
sure and the google research i must be
allergic to this food i gotta go
gluten-free it was a little bit scarier
what i was coming up with where was your
where was it hitting you physically
where were you manifesting so my whole
life
let's just talk about darkness so i have
so many other questions like pushing on
that but i think we can just get dive
deeper now just because i think it's
that's the relatable part
is that people people get these symptoms
they have physical
manifestations i've had them um it's not
like it happens every week but it can
happen
actually every day there can be pings i
would call them like a ping where you
feel it in your heart you feel it in
your gut
you know um there's an awareness in your
mind something like that but then
there's the bigger ones which have
happened a few times which is
like where you can't eat where you are
on well um
so um so let's yeah i mean if you're
willing to share the dark knight of the
soul
you know i think that this could be a
really helpful story for people yeah 100
and i agree i think that a lot of the
symptoms or the issues that we're
struggling with sometimes on a daily
basis sometimes to a catastrophic
degree where we're we can't work anymore
or you know things are actually breaking
down
i believe i mean what holistic means to
me i call myself the holistic
psychologist
what that means to me is yes the mind
the body and the soul are all connected
but also i think what it means to me is
that there's a driving like when
something's in balance when the symptoms
are there like i said whether they're
the daily pings that you're talking
about or the big catastrophes that
happen
i believe at least they don't come from
anywhere they're related to the system
specifically probably a deeper imbalance
in one of those systems
in our body in our physiology a lot of
us have
unbalanced physiology or dysregulated
nervous systems that cause our symptoms
whether they're in our minds we're
living maybe too much in our mind we're
living by i call them narratives
older stories that aren't serving us
anymore
and i believe we have a soul so what an
imbalance in one or all of those systems
can cause those those symptoms so for me
as long as i can remember i've always
had kind of
digestive stuff going on never really
just a clean digestive system so that's
been one that i think i can trace back
from birth oh wow from birth as long as
you can remember
literally as long as yeah quite
literally not like as an adult but
you're right
yeah and interestingly enough my whole
family system
more or less had similar digestive
issues so here's even more
right old model oh well the why is
because genetically
i was gifted with this digestive problem
or i've come to know
the why now is is that we're all living
in a in a system
that maybe isn't the most balanced so
we're all showing the same symptom of
gastro
you know disturbances or whatever you
want to call them but it wasn't
genetically connected as i once thought
it was because of
those imbalances so that's been as long
as i can remember
mind's anxiety so it's in the stomach
the clenching
the panic attacks i mean panic attacks
are a symptom of an underlying imbalance
so that was pretty much the digestive my
whole life in my 20s
i would say my panic attacks really
started to reach an all-time high
my probably the whole decade of my 20.
can you explain a panic attack
to me absolutely so i mean a panic
attack essentially is feels like a heart
attack for a lot of us
some of us go i almost took even though
i know knew about panic attacks
i was so convinced that this was
definitely not the panic attack that
feels like a heart attack it must have
been the heart attack so
it feels sometimes like shortness of
breath constriction
sometimes we get hot we might faint our
heart is
pounding what's the circumstance is
there a circumstance or any time
really it can be anything some of us
have anxieties connected to a thing
i'm afraid of flying right so if when i
fly
are you afraid of a friend no no but i
know people that are afraid of it and
they'll take xanax and they'll
you know they're very they'll need to
drink yeah i used to have a low grade
not to the extent that i've heard some
people have flight anxiety but
so it can be attached to something
specific like flying like
heights and then in those circumstances
i might have this panic attack but it
can also not be
so my the panic attacks i started having
maybe weren't necessarily connected to
anything in my external environment
it was just dysregulation and they
started for me
at a period of time where my mom was who
was been chronically ill pretty much
my whole life but she was starting to
have some serious heart issues so
a lot of my anxiety was so sometimes
it's more internal and so it's something
to worry about that was health-related
that tended to be the the look of my
anxiety to begin with
so then i started to have panic the more
acute you know kind of
if we think of anxiety i think about it
like a um
kind of like a mountain right that panic
is like the tip of it
we could have low grade anxiety and
never peak up into that panic some
people will never have a panic attack
but some will
but it feels like a heart attack and
it's a very physiological visceral
experience like your body is actually
going through something
yeah like and you can see it yeah if
someone's around you they might even
look white you might
giving you signs and symptoms yeah and
that's a beautiful
example of the connection between the
mind and the body so for me right if
this was my mom my mom nervous my mom my
mom and her anxiety and then my body
is having this whole full-blown reaction
so what was it like growing up for you
in in philadelphia i grew up in
philadelphia and you just moved to
venice
and i just congratulated venice i just
which is actually part of my whole
evolution story um but so growing up for
me anxiety is all i knew
my i have a very interest a more
interesting family uh circumstance
because my brother and my sister
are 15 and 18 years older than me wow so
i was born to older parents
and i'm 37 so i was born in 82 so when
my
my mom found out she was pregnant with
me it was
it was concerning because she was 42 and
in 82. i don't know where exactly the
time
when's your birthday then september okay
mine's in march 15th so yeah
so it was i say that because i think
generationally things have evolved and
now you know
later 30s women early 40s women we kind
of understand that yeah there may be
higher risk
pregnancies sure they back then they
were very much looking at possibilities
of down syndrome but that's part of my
story because
my mom is health anxiety herself so when
she said there was even more than doubt
she was pregnant with me
at 42 with the doctors actually looking
her in the face and saying hey
there's could be something wrong with
your child just what she needed to hear
with someone that already has my sister
was chronically ill so it was just whole
like kind of just bubbling circumstance
of anxiety brewing
upon my arrival so when i say my whole
childhood was painted with this
underlying
anxiety but it was never talked about of
course
no name was ever given it you know and
even if it was
normal it's normal it was just a normal
fight or flight and that kind of anxious
always something and always something is
actually a mantra in my family
that kind of mentality really does
illustrate i think the
more extreme version of living in that
fight or flight i mean that was
real for us it did feel like it was
always
looking back sure from a distance i'm
like well you know
like the the grass not getting cut to
your liking
doesn't feel like always something to me
right now
but it did it did there's such a
connection between you know when i just
don't have the resources and i'm
chronically in that fight or flight
everything does feel like always
something
was your dad did your dad have anxiety
too my dad didn't
he was all he's i kind of he he's a bit
on the periphery if i were to paint like
a he's a bit passive
he isn't he isn't but he wouldn't have
had anxiety but he was very much
enmeshed or really interconnected with
my mom and with hers
so i i say or the way i describe it i
don't know if the listeners have ever
heard of a concept called codependency
or a meshed relationship i think people
have heard of codependency
but even i'm just learning what it is
because it's you know the the
explanation of it which yeah please
explain codependency
yeah and that's the first thing that
came to mind when i heard you start
talking about your dad
exactly he's very passive he was in some
way supportive
almost and enabling yes 100 percent
those are those are definitely words and
a lot of times so listeners might have
heard codependency
referenced in terms of substance use or
addiction a lot of times you should
hear about the codependent personality
that often then manifests in that i
i believe that actually more of us than
than not
sit on the more codependent end of the
spectrum if you would have asked me a
decade ago though danica if i was
codependent i would have looked at you
laughed
said not at all definitely i knew what
codependency was a decade ago
i just didn't know how that it applied
to me so when i talk about it now i talk
about a much more expanded definition of
it because like i said i do believe
a lot of us are struggling with that in
our relationships for a lot of different
reasons
essentially what it is though is a
blurring so i'm a person
if we think about me with like a little
kind of cell memory and around a circle
around yeah right so
to be in a healthy relationship i
believe in interdependence so
there is a space like we we are social
creatures
we benefit from relationships relating
with others
help even just from division of labor to
stress reduction
we need relationships but to have the
healthiest relationship we need that
barrier where i can still
maintain a sense of self that's nicole's
separate from danica's
if we were in whatever right this is
professional relationships
friendships personal relationships of
all kinds romantic relationships
parental relationships
i am the relationship is only as
successful i think
as we can have that separation where i
can make whether just my choices about
what i want to do
for any day and this might sound silly
but it's a lot of us that
don't know how we want to spend our time
and maybe look
to someone else or worry about the
effects of how i want to spend my time
how that would
affect someone else so like if i have a
partner right i feel like i always have
to check in
what are we doing saturday partner
instead of well saturday i want to do
this and it's okay partner if you don't
want to do this with me
so it can be anything from behaviors
like what i want to do how i want to
send my time
to thoughts right a separation where i
can allow you to have separate beliefs i
can have separate beliefs
a lot of times families this is where
this originates
my family we had mantras we had things
that the lapera's believed
this is what we believe as a unit with
no space for well
maybe nicole or you know my sister over
here believes differently
and then feelings and i think this is
the area where when i said that
catch-all we all are a little
co-dependent
i think a lot of us connect our feelings
with someone else's
meaning i it's like i talk about it like
a roller coaster
right so where i'm reacting emotionally
to the emotions everyone else is having
in the world to what they think of me
so that's another barrier that we want
to put into place where i can have my
feelings because we're all different
things are going to affect me
differently than they affect you and
again back to that healthy relationship
i think there needs to be space
where i can have feelings that might be
separate from other people's
and where i don't gain my value based on
how i feel about myself
based on other people right so for all
of these reasons my family very much
looked like a
system that just whether it was what we
were doing
you were all in the bubble we tended to
do it like we i joke i say we all like
going
i mean now looking back that 20 year old
me that would have laughed about
codependency i mean we practically come
out of a clown car sometimes danica we
like
we i call it squad life like we we go a
lot of we historically we went a lot of
places together we spent a lot of time
together as a family
yeah then there was that group think in
terms of belief
yeah and then for my family it was this
is where my dad comes in
the emotional climate really orbited
around my mom
and when my mom was in you know when
everything was positive with mom
mainly when she was healthy and like up
and walking
and you know of the family we all felt
good
but when mom wasn't or when mom was in a
bad mood
the whole family felt bad so that's what
i was describing in terms of the
emotions so
our emotions really orbited around my
mom's and my dad got really
connected so it became my mom and my dad
my dad
really just serving my mom in terms of
making sure that my mom was okay and he
defended her so that the fact that he
defended her too then was that he didn't
defend this is where the passivity came
in
okay so when she would do things that i
don't even know what he
i guess sometimes i do know my mom likes
to when she's upset ice
not speak i call it icing yeah so there
have been this is the more extreme
version of this too and this didn't
happen often but when it would happen
this is where my dad's passivity comes
in
i don't know if he would directly tell
me he wasn't into my mom's icing
so say i was the one who's being ice
which i have been so he wouldn't
directly say hey nicole like i don't
really agree that mom's doing that so
but
indirectly i don't think he agreed
however
he would maybe and he would actually not
saying things my mom's
i allow it not that i right not that he
can only change someone or not i don't
believe one can change anyone but
he would allow it he would like
indirectly participate in that way
and i don't think this ever happened
with me but my sister has memories of
their my dad would even go as far as to
pass notes
you know if my mom like wanted to pass a
note to someone who with whom she was
not speaking
she really really was icing would be the
note passer so that's what i mean when i
say the passive
so he was like condoning it literally
fast in a way
and literally passing notes so very
interesting wow
so that's that's how it remained until i
became conscious enough to look at that
and to understand
that maybe that didn't that wasn't the
healthiest and that didn't allow for
freedom and
i was always the one that was a little
bit on that outer orbit challenging them
with how i looked and what i said and
what i wanted to do
thoughts but i was always kept within
an orbit right i was never fully
released
to be you know kind of separate entirely
so did the dark night of the soul come
while you were in the orbit
so it wasn't after the dark knight of
the soul did come when i was in the
orbit so once
and maybe dark knight is soul we should
explain what that is because these are
all things that
when you're integrated into the world of
spirituality and holistic perspectives
and
woo as someone would call like you've
heard of all these things but even then
sometimes it's hard to know really
really what that means but
for a lot of people they maybe have
never heard of what this is and so this
isn't an
this isn't necessarily an expression
this is um
an experience experience 100 so
what is it what it is is essentially a
lot of people
kind of connected to actually the soul
and the soul speaking and the soul
you know if if you are of the belief
that humans are gifted with a mind body
and a soul it's this idea that we are
something that's beyond just our
physical presence and the thoughts that
we have in our head that there's a
in essence that's us and a lot of times
which is what it is described as
is a series of symptoms i'll tell you
what mayan ended up evolving
into but it's a series of symptoms that
are really connected to that
some people say it's your skull your
soul screaming out
just an imbalance where there's a lack
of i think about it like this a lack of
alignment
in one or more areas of your life
so my normal like i said was was anxiety
was this get was this gastro stuff that
came along with it i had some beautiful
panic attacks
very connected to my family system
trudging along
having a practice and then very
gradually
really see like physical symptoms
started to creep in even more i started
to faint
i had never fainted before um
i started i lost i would lose the train
of my thinking mid-sentence it happened
once with
with the client sitting across from me
could not i mean we all lose our train
of thought oh and i can like
i can i'm very gifted talking my way
back to something that's assembling so
anyway
you know that that i can like i was
saying yeah i could get through
or like kind of dance my way around a
lost train of thought
in this moment it was actually it almost
felt it's so indescribable like my brain
just went
shut off went blank and someone was
sitting in front of me so i had to
acknowledge to the person like oh i'm
sorry i'm just
and i got that that one really spooked
me a little bit and then that became
something that was happening a lot i was
forgetting names
so i had all of this cognitive stuff so
when i said i was scared i was
of course convinced it's something in my
my brain i have a tumor
yeah this is the thing that i've been
waiting for all along here i mean how
could it not be now i'm actually like
falling
down i'm part of your head i'm like i'm
like all this cognitive stuff's
happening
so that's when i went on my whole
journey of research and
in that i came to discover this whole
world so i i came to realize that for my
dark night of the soul those symptoms
the top level
were related to physiological imbalances
just
lifestyle choices that i was making even
though i thought i was making
very well intentioned i was trying to
make healthier choices in my life
there was a lot of misinformation there
was just a lot of ways that i didn't
really fully understand
nutrition and the importance of sleep
and you know kind of all the body stuff
um so my dark night of the soul the
physical symptoms were related to that
physiological imbalances so in my
journey i discovered all these lifestyle
changes that i wanted to make
i also came to realize that part of my
dark night of the soul was just that
that imbalanced in my relationships
because i was so codependent
i developed a habit a lifelong habit up
until that point
of putting everyone else and their wants
and their needs before me because
remember if mom's happy i get to be
happy
so i just transferred that into all my
relationships if my friend's happy i'm
happy if my partner's happy i'm happy if
my colleagues happy i'm happy if
everyone's happy
i'm happy but i never really asked
myself
what i needed in those moments first so
that led to a lot of imbalanced
behaviors things that i was doing for
other people
quite literally at the expense of myself
you can never rely on somebody else to
make you happy a hundred percent of the
time you can't do it at all
it's you know and it actually is really
toxic for relationships because before
you know it if i show up for you
time and time and time again danica
there's going to come a point somewhere
down the line where
i'm mad at you not me i get mad at you
for not giving back to me but
i have to look at the condition that i
set up i never asked you to i never
requested you to i never said no when i
needed to say no
yeah but what it looks like is
resentment i get mad at you and then our
relationship could quite literally come
to an
end because that's typically what
happens so it's impossible
no one can make you happy and it really
does kill
kill relationships and then the soul
piece of my dark knight of the soul
was really coming to the realization
that i was living out of alignment that
the things that i was
prophesizing and the way i was teaching
and thinking about
myself and others in the world just
wasn't connected
with because even in those moments there
was many times where i was
doing myself a disservice by not
speaking my truth my soul
truth so before you know all of these
imbalances
led to literally so that would happen
within your practice all the time
so things that you weren't things that
you might have wanted to say that you
didn't say looked more like that yeah i
would never speak
right mistruths right but i would leave
it out
leave it out not be as direct you know
to confront something that i maybe
knew was there uh and then at the end as
i
so i continued to practice doing just my
i had my practice so i continued with my
practice as i was learning all this
so then it started to look like wow now
i know all of these other truths
that i'm not and every now and again i
would try to share it with some of my
clients
it wasn't that i was withholding it but
the conversation that i had
professionally with myself
was i set up an arrangement with these
people to do this type of work that was
the contract essentially so
i would try with the clients that i
thought might be open to hey nutrition
matters or hey
sleep matters and some of them we
evolved the practice
together and i would talk about these
truths that i was now gaining
and living and healing with but i
couldn't do that with all of my clients
so the ones that i didn't it did feel
like i was living this double life
like i'm part of that box it wasn't part
of that i would talk to you
i would just support you along the way
and really i knew all this other stuff
that might also be helpful
so it felt like that was a difficult i
think kind of segue
portion where i was trying to navigate
because financially i had i had to keep
my practice going there was just no
other option
so trying to navigate that transition
period was also another
you didn't have 1.7 million followers i
did not but that was a big that was
that was incredibly helpful being able
to share on instagram
and see the resonance so i had that were
you sharing while you were still so what
i did was oh very interesting i made the
decision to go on instagram
as an outlet to me for two sure to speak
my truth to have an area where i could
start to say these things that i was
learning so that helped relieve some of
it
so that was helpful and another one was
i'd gotten to the part of my healing
that i think is also
part of dark night of the soul which i
was so lonely
i was feeling so isolated i was making
all these choices and having all these
awarenesses and reorganizing so many
long-term relationships
and i was feeling really isolated about
around
people who got me i wasn't feeling like
i had people who were
understanding exactly maybe what i'd
been through or where i was going
so that was a big motivator too because
your new life's gonna cost your old one
yes
and that takes time that was really yeah
so i think a lot of us when we start to
come to these awarenesses and do the
work of healing and i talk about this a
lot because i think people
it's hard it's isolating it feels lonely
how how long did dark knight soul last
for you or is it still going i know it
can be a long process
uh i would say that the probably about
two years was a was the deepest part of
it with the increase in those physical
symptoms
leading to that kind of apex of it and
then even through the process of healing
a lot of it was coming up and releasing
so
how did you i'm gonna just call it like
get out
i mean from the family dynamic the yeah
the the norm like how did you break out
of that
cycle absolutely so when i first i did
the research and i armed myself with the
changes that i was interested in making
and then i did what i profess everyone
should do which is i took them gradually
i talk a lot about small daily promises
so because change is hard there's a lot
of reasons why
in our in our brain structure the mind
the subconscious in particular yeah if
you follow me i'm all excited hormones
patterns
i want to normalize that too though
because i think a lot of us and i was
who are really hard on ourselves
why can't we change you know why can't
we do these things that by now we know
are so good for us like i know it
why can't i can i do habits and there's
a real reason why because it's hard
because we're all fighting
that kind of reflex that we all have
that desire to be in the familiar even
if the familiar logically
isn't going to better our life whether
it's our familiar habits
or our familiar thoughts we just like
that it's familiar our
subconscious belief is safe well there's
a whole hormonal
cycle that happens with familiar
responses and
living your life a certain way there's
like hormonal
uh it's like you're programmed to crave
that hormone that gets produced every
time there's a drama
or a sadness or whatever your cycle is
is that right 100 i couldn't and i call
this the process of emotional addiction
so we get so so i'll just use my example
now you know a bit of my story
chaos and stress that's those are the
two words i said more often than not
when sharing my
history right there's hormones connected
with that cortisol and adrenaline
so because i got so my body so thoughts
right i'm stressed
the family crisis of the minute whatever
it was caused a stressful thought
caused a stress response in my body even
at my nervous system level
so cortisol and adrenaline are the
hormones that are dispatched through my
body to get my body ready to fight or
flee
right because my body actually thinks in
that moment that the
the lack of lawn care is a threat i mean
this is evolutionary base so my body's
going to gear me up to fight the threat
so these hormones curing through my body
they cause all these changes
and then my nervous system snaps over
into the sympathetic
so i'm having you know my body is
getting ready to fight this thing
there's nothing to fight right but that
becomes my cycle that happens frequently
enough
before i know it my baseline my body
memorizes that zone that's all that's
how it feels
familiar so if you would have heard me
talk up until more recently where i feel
like i do live in peace
all i would say i want it on this planet
here is peace
i just want peace i want peace and
freedom those are the two words that i
would always talk about
and the most interesting thing i started
to observe when i had what one might
think would be a peaceful day
or afternoon or vacation there was
something so uncomfortable about it
early on or my whole life okay so like
now i can embody peace i can sit in
peace so what this looked like for me i
used to call it my
it's an agitation so mayan i would i
would call it my tail
i would start to so i was laying lounge
and reading all saturday nothing to do
peace
one might call it i was so uncomfortable
without that stimulation because it
wasn't familiar because it wasn't
familiar so
peace felt crazy uncom uncomfortable
far in so one of two things would happen
i would either feel like i had all this
energy
that i would i call it tick out clean i
would be i'm
busy myself throughout the day
describing me right now to try to get my
energy out
or i would poke at i
if i was in a relationship i would try
to find an interpersonal
stress that i could engage with
to remove myself from that unfamiliar
piece
back to what i was used to stress so now
it's something to worry about god
i mean honestly i i that you're
describing me and now
i can look at it from like a an esoteric
perspective of astrology or something
like that about being a fire sign and an
aries and i can look at it from that way
and see
the energy and needing to move it but i
have i can't sit around like i feel
and i know part of it like part of it
i'm aware that as i was
like growing up i wasn't allowed to do
nothing like i had to
wake up early i had to accomplish
something i had to do something it was
rewards for doing something
and but relaxing and doing nothing
i either feel lazy or boring like if i'm
by myself i could
i feel lazy if i'm with someone else i
feel boring or lazy like but boring i'm
like oh
should we go for a walk should we do
something and it is it's almost like a
nervous tic like i'm
unable to deregulate
a running joke in my family my middle
name actually was
nicole i'm bored so it wasn't that i was
boring
but i would always as a child on board
play with me where my favorite two lines
and that was that underlying agitation
that i didn't know
what it was there's still and this is
different conversation that i believe
i mean i know our bodies are energy i
believe we
need to move our bodies and discharge
energy yeah to maintain that equilibrium
so it's not to say
don't do anything when i'm lying you
know my body is actually saying
nicole there's energy here that i would
like to be moved around so go take that
walk or
yeah or go you know yeah do the thing
yeah um so it's different
however i'm saying i can't ever do it
like it never really feels good if it's
hard
and that's why i know because i should
be able to relax sometimes right yeah
but i really feel like a lot of things
it could be it could be just that range
of normal
familiar sometimes in stopping the
deeper stuff comes up we're met with
ourselves i mean there's a lot of
reasons
and i think this is epidemic level like
a lot of us can't stop
we have a culture of busyness we you
know we value productivity
and the markings of never sleeping doing
all the things
um and it's no coincidence i think a lot
of us are chasing those things because
we
feel better than we feel when we're just
stopped
because then we're just with ourself and
we don't have all the distractions in
place
so we allow to come up maybe some of the
deeper stuff that we'd rather not
look at sorry i distracted my own oh
[ __ ] moment but
um as i i'm all very hard work around
myself but more to go um
so but i want to get to this because i
think that
a lot of people can relate i know a lot
of people can relate
but there's always that moment there
that you have to
break free you have to sever ties you
have to
create boundaries there has to be you've
talked a lot about boundaries
and you know how did that was there like
a
one day where you sat down with your
family or was this a
was this a progressive thing that
happened over time where
contact was reduced but like how did you
get to the point where you
finally felt like
i'm free so it was once i started making
those small daily lifestyle changes that
i did that and i was still having a
relationship with my family so
that took a couple months to get my body
stabilized so
i addressed kind of the physical person
first and i think that's necessary
because like i was saying with those
there's imbalances i was doing a lot of
polyvagal work which is so we have a
nerve and it to keep it really short and
simple so when we're in fight or flight
when we're stressed
when we're panicked when we have ptsd
we're just under low level you know kind
of stress
our our nervous system is in that
sympathetic state
the alternate nervous system again this
is a very loose description is called
the parasympathetic
and there's a nerve it's called the
vagal nerve
the vagus nerve that kind of helps us
we're supposed a healthy tone is when we
can use both of our nervous systems when
necessary
when we're in a peaceful state we're in
our parasympathetic and we're calm and
all of our body systems are
in the calm state we can sleep we're
digesting
and then we shift over because we do
need our sympathetic nervous system
when we need it and then we go back very
you know
seamlessly so i was doing a lot of vegas
work because when you are stuck as a lot
of us are we can be stuck in
sympathetic in fight or flight like i
was with stress and anxiety and panic
we can also be stuck in parasympathetic
which looks a little more like what we
think of when we think of depression
my mood is low i have no interest i'm
almost so off i'm so
turned off think about it right i'm on
i'm yeah i'm anxious i'm stressed
the lion's going to eat me i better yeah
literally and now i'm so
i have no energy no interest i'm in bed
all day so so we can get
stuck again i'm using really simplified
line we can get stuck
in either of those so the vegas we
really want to tone so i was doing the
physiological lifestyle work i was
changing what i ate
sleeping et cetera and i was doing the
polyvagal work and then i started to
gain some traction my
i started to feel balanced i started to
have the polyvagals what then
it's a so polyvagal work is connected to
the vagus nerve so it looks like breath
work
okay okay so we can actually manually
stimulate our
biggest nerves there's okay there's
medical equipment out there that they
can do it but the beautiful part of it
is we can do it too okay
and the quick and easys that i always
reference is just a breath work practice
a particular way of actually a deep
belly breath is our
quickest way in so we learn how to
breathe so if anyone listening or
put a hand on our chest and on our belly
most of the listeners will probably
notice that you're breathing very
shallow from your chest uh-huh
that is a marker of that sympathetic
nervous system in and of itself because
think about it when we're running from
our predator we're not taking those nice
deep belly breaths
we're panting or running you're tense
you're tense
so the there's a many different breath
work practices that stimulate
the vegas but the belly one is something
you could do all day just
breath into your belly just so you might
look how does it work i put hand on my
belly to get started
i have i carry some of my emotions in my
posture
so others listening might also have a
hard time doing this
i started by laying down so i would lay
down as part of my morning routine
and just give myself put my hand on my
belly to make sure i was breathing into
the belly
and just five belly breaths with enough
practice
then that's a breathing that you can do
all day long so then i continued to
build on that so
all day i would just practice when i
remembered of course that wasn't natural
sure and now i've retrained my whole
nervous system then i'm pretty much
a belly breather and i can catch myself
now when one of two things when i either
moved up to my chest or when i hold my
breath
what a great indication i notice i hold
my breath and listeners out there would
experiment observe how you breathe we
don't i mean breathing is something that
our body does for us thank you body
but we also can consciously attend to it
and i notice
that when i'm feeling stressed i will
hold my breath not in like a
you know like i'm holding my breath but
and almost a unknown like it's just a
behind the scenes like i'm not really
breathing
so even sometimes just the intention to
take a deep breath
we start off like that as babies right
don't babies all belly breathing
yeah anyone has an infant out there look
at your little infant and you'll see
yeah belly
it's all and then just over time we all
just gradually evolve
up to that chest so we really want to
push our breath down to what i look
weird over here it's because i'm going
to focus on my
belly it could go along and then i'm
just going to fall asleep right here
yeah it could go a long way
yeah this is really important too for
just emotional regulation
because our body reacts and when we're
in a
difficult conversation right if i don't
like what you're saying to me sure
so as not to react like i don't want to
if i can just deploy some of that belly
breathing
it's not going to take it all away but
it could give us a little bit of control
whereas i would just have maybe lost
control and take the edge off yeah
yeah before so i spent a lot of time
doing both of those things getting my
body in order
and then my mind started to clear i had
i had at that point developed a daily
meditation practice
i think it's incredibly important to be
conscious
to absolutely how long let's be
realistic start with one minute
great thank you quite literally it's
just everyday small when i say small
daily promise i mean small because the
consistency
yeah is what's important i don't even
think you need to so what my daily
meditation practice now looks like
i meditate for around 10 to 20 minutes
depending on
if i do a guided one or if i'm just
sitting every day maybe some days not
even up to 10 you know it depends
yeah um what i believe is most important
so when we're meditating we're
developing a new relationship with our
thinking mind
most of us spend too much time in our
thoughts we allow our thoughts to rule
our life we think our thoughts are us
we think that our intuition speaking to
us really that that's the house of all
that conditioning
all the things that aren't helpful to us
so what i believe is most important is
practicing consciousness all day long
so instead of building up to even an
hour
some people will i mean i was actually
just watching a really inspiring
documentary
um of someone who meditates for an hour
each day and i thought i might
try that that's not necessary what is
more important in my opinion
is consciously living your day is being
able to observe yourself your thoughts
having that separation really tuning
into that that soul
or whatever you want to call it that you
that's not your thinking mind i assure
you
none of us are thinking well you you've
said that one of the things that
you what you really hope people take
away from your work
is that for people to become aware of
the fact that you are
not who you think you are yes so what do
you mean by that yeah you are not i mean
we have all
you're not what you think you are yeah
we have all of who do we think we are
right you think we are
our habits the things we do if you yeah
if you describe if you ask people you'll
see that
right we think we're the things we do
maybe the things we do with our body how
our body looks
sure right we think we think beliefs
about ourselves some of which we were
told you know oh you're shy
oh you're outgoing oh this is who you
are this is
we think the thoughts that we rehearse
are we tended we're so habitual we're
habitual in our behaviors yeah we're
habitual in our thoughts if you start to
tune in and be conscious and observe
your thoughts
most of us will see that they're very i
call them narratives because they're
repetitive they're the same story yeah
whether it's the story i'm telling me
about myself
about my relationships my place in the
world other people
story story stories and we think we're
the feelings that we're used to having
but if we look back at the development
of all of this
we are we are that awareness that's what
we will remain however
over time right we've stored all of this
other crap
all of the our habits have been stored
because that's what we were taught we
were taught that's how you take care of
your body or that's what you do in the
morning or that's not what you do in the
morning
we've been rehearsing thoughts for so
long that now they're beliefs
that's who we think we are we have a
story essentially that lives in our mind
that that's who we think we are
and i am now a liver of the experience
of that's not who we are we are the
awareness
and while those are conditioned i use
the word conditioning a lot those are
condition
patterns we can uncondition ourselves
and we can give ourselves freedom
to make new choices so when i started to
practice at dale this is where the
family stuff really started to get
involved in my healing
as i started to observe myself and watch
the thoughts i was having when i'm
around my family thoughts about my
family in general thoughts that were
coloring my other relationships that
were connected to my family
as i started to observe how i felt
around my family and other people that i
was relating to how do you feel
when you're when you're going to hang
out with this person how do you feel
when you're hanging out with
these people how do you feel when you
leave these people and so i started to
observe
that's when i really had the reckoning
because up until this point i was
healing my family was in my life like i
didn't really consider
my partner was starting to drop very
kindly and
lovingly some of her observations that
she was gathering along the way but not
pushing and
i was very defensive no my family is not
like that you're talking about that it's
not they're fine
the case you know you are unloving and
not supportive partner don't ever say
that again it's very
hard to talk about someone else's family
there's a lot of defensiveness
i'm joking now but that's i i will
readily admit i was not
welcoming i did that too information i
did not want to hear it i did not like
it and i put her
i cast her as doing something wrong by
even trying to tell me these things
i wasn't ready is the point so as i
continued though so then i
was like okay well she's saying it let
me just look let me just see
from myself what does that look like
what is when you say
you would observe how you felt before
you observe how you feel
during you observe how you feel after
this is like
the call to action now that's one thing
to think it right
but then you go do it and you're like oh
i don't know it seemed fine so
what can someone do to to
to really understand how they felt and
observe themselves before during and
after what is the technique
yeah absolutely so i think it all begins
with the body
first and this doesn't just ha so
listener oh i'm gonna go do this
tomorrow
probably not because two things will
have to happen first you have to
practice the skill of observing
observing
right of of watching yourself and this
kind of kind of hold my hand up like i'm
kind of hovering above
yeah we can do that yeah we have a
really amazing
mind we are all gifted great but you
have to practice that
yeah right otherwise i'm just reacting
to life as its throat at me so i have to
be able to hear what you're saying
right and to also observe that what
you're saying is making me think this
thing and feel this thing so we have to
be able to
kind of have that look so that's a skill
that has and that's
not gonna happen when you're walking
into an uncomfortable situation
this is just a primer that i want to say
for all of these tools
we need them when we need them but to
use them effectively when we need them
we have to start practicing them
when it's not as hard so i great just
observing myself all of the time knowing
that when i'm going back to my family of
origin and the feelings that are
connected they're going to get
you know kind of touched and like
triggered if you will that it's going to
be harder for me to do this because i
probably will go back into the same
thing i always do
which is cope and tell myself it's fine
yeah and not feel
and not feel like oh yeah it just seemed
normal so just connect myself and that
was a big part of my
past and now my future journey and
healing is so
i was talking earlier and i had looted
and i used language
of lacking a memory so part of my story
is because i was so overwhelmed by
anxiety and stress that was too much for
me as a child
and i didn't have the caregivers in
place to help me so when when you have a
child
big feelings are happening so a parent
or caregiver
has to help that child understand what's
happening and learn to navigate their
emotions
yeah so without that in absence of that
because i was so overwhelmed the gift of
our
our mind is that it will never let us be
overwhelmed yeah
find a way to cope yeah the ego does a
good job at that i mean don't be mad at
the ego it does a good job of protecting
you
the ego but it's only looking at the
very moment you're in 100 and i will
always i'm a bit i'm a big proponent of
the ego it's necessary it protected us
it did what we needed it to do
um so at the time the adaptation that i
made was to do what is called
dissociating which is detaching
which is i call it my spaceship i used
to go away in
and it was as if and on the outside you
would never know
i would appear here i could have a full
conversation with you
but in terms of attachment to my body i
wasn't in my body
i wasn't connected i couldn't tell you
how my body even like physiologically
felt let alone the emotions
sure that i was having but i could
navigate the situation and that was a
form of protection so i was up on my
spaceship
hovering safely above the things that
were too difficult for me to feel
you removed every last bit of yourself
other than the one that just was there
whatever to power it out and i got this
is where i got really good this is where
this codependency started
at showing up the way you needed me to
because i was so attuned to you
to fit in to preserve the love from you
and this you whether it's my mom or my
friend at school or you know the boss
that i would later have
that was important so because i was
myself wasn't there i was fully
available to you
and i got really good at that so i could
tell exactly i could feel you
i could know what people want it what
they need it from me in the moment and
that's that codependency i was talking
about earlier
so i showed up in certain shape-shifting
other people of other people
of other people time and time and time
again so how did you um
how did you learn how did you figure out
who you were
it's it's a journey in progress so this
goes back to
so grounding myself so when i when i
talk and i talk about this often
i talk about having no memories and a
lot of the the reason i have no memories
is because i wasn't connected enough
in those moments to put the memory in
huh and the big aha yeah
or a big i relate to that because i was
convinced annika that i must have this
was back to this brain issue that i was
just waiting to descend upon me i knew i
didn't have memories for
some time probably in my 20s i started
to hear other people talk about their
childhood in ways that
i didn't know what mine was like so i
started to
kind of realize that my autobiographical
story was a little bit absent compared
like i'm missing the first four chapters
those people around me
yeah and so that but i thought it was
something in my brain that was wrong
with me oh must be something that's like
just
off in my brain so long story short i
start talking about that online when i
go online and i start to realize
that talk about being connected
disconnected from our authentic self
so many of us lack memories in different
extremes but because they're so
disconnected
so as i started to come to that
awareness
and realize that i had removed myself
from all of my relationships beginning
with my family of origin i was not
connected to my body in any way
then i started to practice reconnecting
with my body
and breaking that habit of dissociating
was so incredibly difficult and that
looked like
the tool that i always talk about using
because we all have them
is our senses so anything when you are
using something
sensory what i'm seeing what i'm
smelling when i'm tasting what i'm
hearing
they are only active in the present
moment where the thing
the sensory item is yeah per se right
so using those tools as attention hooks
or those those senses so
just literally focusing what am i seeing
in this moment
can i feel my body in this chair right
breathing can i focus my attention back
into my body and
through the act of breathing that those
are grounding techniques i just
i mean literally just saw that in the
chair and i just went and here you are
and i honestly just felt my
like shoulders drop i'm like oh there
you are yeah oh
that feels good yeah and a lot of us
like presents
spending time there so that's where it's
great begins and
grounding it's through those so that's
how i broke my habit of dissociation i
came back down
so how do i tune it came back down from
your spaceship yeah i landed my
spaceship it's now been retired
i've given it away to the next person
yeah you haven't seen this spaceship in
a while i've seen the spaceship it's
been a minute
it's funny though i have the spaceship
emoji i just saw it on my
phone for the first time i was like oh
damn where was this when i needed it i'm
going to store your phone with a
spaceship no i'm not i'm not going to
perpetuate
that cycle
but so to to answer your question we
have to be in our bodies
to know how we're feeling in any moment
so the practice
first is grounding yourself is learning
how to reconnect learning how to be
in your body some of us will find the
things like so for some of us i'm going
my ear
music some people will find their
ability to be present
a little bit easier through music for me
it's always been nature
yeah when i'm in nature that can grab my
attention allow me to be present in my
body in a different way so
you're going to want to the listeners
are going to want to practice being in
their body
yeah so that they can then practice
observing how their body that's how it
started for me with music in nature so i
listen to very
zen music in nature and then it got to
the point where
yeah but that's how it started yep so so
first you're gonna be in your body and
then your body's gonna tell you so then
what that look like for me
is okay how do i feel when my phone
buzzes and it's my sister or my mom or
how do i feel when i know i'm going to
see them
this weekend yeah how do i so where are
you feeling in your body also
right are you feeling in your heart
you're feeling your stomach you feeling
it like is there a gut reaction
and i would start to feel like a tension
yeah and a tightness yeah
just a not positive right not relaxed
not relaxed there is a reaction and that
happens so i like
i i've come to now realize that i'm now
cultivating
relationships that are much more in
alignment and to have the experience of
leaving someone or something and feeling
light
and positive was was foreign and it
might be foreign to people listening
because they might not
have those you know relationships or
environments in their life and
i know i didn't for a long time and now
that i do it's such a contrast it's like
oh
that's what it's like to be around
someone that's in vibrational alignment
with you versus
oh i'm going to the people that i really
don't want to be spending
sure my time around so as i allowed that
was hard well you just you talked about
how
at first you felt lonely right you're
not in a vibrational alignment with
anyone around you
exactly so that you could feel this you
had the shift happening yourself
but they were still where they were at
so there was a lack of resonance with
you
and your environment yeah you can feel
that you feel that you know you feel
when you're in it too
yes yeah you feel it all so i started to
be
aware of these feelings and then i
started to make so this was a very
gradual evolution then i started to
realize that i needed boundaries so
boundaries are so back to that
codependency right i am there's
no circle there's no membrane around me
i needed to build one
so i needed to define limits for myself
so a lot of those limits
were within my family too so i came to
the conclusion that there were certain
areas that i wanted to start to
pull back on whether it was how much
time i was available to them
or how did you tell them that emotion i
was available to them and i communicated
at that time
okay so it mainly so the relationship
that i had the most active and the
closest was
was with my sister so she and i would
have many conversations where i would
first my requests were around
i don't really want to talk about mom's
health all the time because it started
to feel like although you said that
i didn't sell that to my sister because
what is a boundary to observe
in our conversations where that 99 of
them were about the latest
health crisis drama at this point none
of which that i would even define as a
crisis this wasn't me
turning my back on my mom who was you
know this was me like my mom has
doctor's appointments almost every month
you know so i'm not gonna
become upset by every doctor's
appointment because there's no need
nothing's
happening in every doctor's appointment
they felt like there was
at every doctor moment but i didn't and
that's where i started to define my
limits so
first it was i don't want to talk about
mom all the time and this was
actually in service so i thought of
building a deeper relationship with my
sister
sure right so he moved mom ninety
percent of the time
yeah a lot more that i could get to know
you and talk to you about
was your mom also a narcissist i mean
was there narcissism
there yeah wrapped up in it because then
i've also heard that there's like
the the another way um it's a like a
narcissist
um like a committee almost like the
narcissist um
like team like a narcissist gets a team
going yeah
and so this is another so if and a
narcissist
is my partner i was gonna say my partner
offered that word narcissist
i did not like it now i understand so
explain what it is that's
what it is so because i think is this a
tough one it's a tough one and i think
and i know that narcissism is getting
talked about a lot
now and i think that's really helpful
yeah i think the type of narcissist
that's being talked about
is the very kind of egocentric it's all
about being a really direct
kind of egotistical the i think this is
where i think ego it's a bad name too
because it's not
the ego that you're previously talking
about but what the listeners would think
of when they think of egotistical
narcissist it's all about me and i don't
care who i stomp on
you know to get what i my needs met
that's the narcissist right
i think that mo is most thought of
when you hear that word reference agree
which is why when my partner first
offered that my mom might be slightly
narcissistic
i thought she was absolutely nuts
because that's not how my mom presents
right it's not the direct she actually
is very much her language is much more
of a
covert narcissist that's the right yes
my mom would much
likely tend to say everyone else before
me
but hers is much more covert but she
would still be so what a narcissist
is essentially is it actually goes back
to that lack of
self so it begins early on when a person
from a very young age doesn't have any
definition of
them as a self them is separate from
someone else
so what happens is the only way that
they can feel good about themselves
is through others and other people
and in a way so with it so it starts in
a very protective
developmental mechanism and then it does
look like
them putting themself first in different
ways emotionally my emotions
guide all of her illnesses right herself
so for my mom that kind of narcissism so
it was a little bit more confusing
because she wasn't running around making
it about me she was actually a little
more behind the scenes it wasn't flashy
but it was covertly
about her because like i said it was how
his mom feels yeah it was mom is she
physically well
she's mentally well are we all happy or
are we not happy based on
based on mom but there was definitely
that was wrong i
i'm gonna say something controversial
maybe not too i believe we're all on a
spectrum
of of nurse i mean i don't necessarily
think it's an unhealthy thing
i would call myself slightly
narcissistic yeah i think we're all more
on the spectrum some of us more extreme
than others but
we are all i mean an ego reaction when
i'm having when i'm upset
by something you say and my upset is so
big is maybe disproportionately big for
what maybe objectively
happened i'm in a narcissistic state
because now my emotion is overwhelming
i don't give a [ __ ] what you're saying
or doing in that moment because it's all
about me
so we all have moments of narcissism
that's what that reaction is when i'm in
an emotional state
when you're affecting other people too
yeah and that could look then outward
so if i kick and scream and tantrum when
i'm upset
in that moment of upset when my upset is
active i might be affecting other people
negatively and
i don't care i might care later and
that's where shame the shame cycle comes
in and i feel so bad about myself
because that's not who i am i didn't
mean to hurt
the people that i've been directly hurt
in that moment maybe
but i couldn't see outside of myself did
you go through that face
of shame and guilt uh
shame i don't i think most the things
that i am shamed about
and remain shameful of though these
moments are
decreasing and frequently now are when i
overreact
when i when my core wounds so a lot of
mine this is really prevalent in
relationships
one of my core wounds is not feeling
considered not feeling seen and hurt as
a separate entity as a child right
comes together so there are so many ways
that i could spend a story of not being
considered in my relationships
sure and when especially you know before
i've done
as much work as i have now done those
would be very very frequent those
stories so anytime something happened in
the context of a relationship where i
would
feel or deem that that was an example of
how i wasn't considered yet again
i would feel about it i would feel
really big i feel hurt i feel
angry so what i would then
retrospectively become shameful of
is how i reacted in those those moments
right if you pour a little bit of
alcohol on top of it i've had my share
of you know raging around upset you know
over a slight thing and then
and then the next day i'm like whoa whoa
whoa like perfect storm what did you do
there you don't even you know this
wasn't a moment of being not considered
so i and and much more infrequent now
but when i go back into that reactivity
that's something that i can
i try not to focus too much time on the
beating myself
up on my own critic but that's i think
the the only area that i
wouldn't actively be dealing with kind
of the shame thing
that's pretty hard to be perfect so you
have to be perfect
yeah what kind of um i mean what phase
are you in right now like what is
what is what are you feeling that you're
working through now i mean you've been
in
on this journey for a long time and
you've gone through huge growth but it
never
ends right so i don't know what's what's
the current
absolutely what's the current current
work in progress absolutely
so i think the current i mean i'm pretty
consistently conscious now which is
awesome my body feels as
balanced and kind of equilibrium as i
think it
ever has i feel like the venice sunshine
and the beaches is definitely helping
compared to philadelphia
helping all of my systems i do believe
that's a part of it yeah i mean i do
believe that
that's important i've done a lot of
boundary work so i'm getting better
at having boundaries whether it's in
professional or personal life that's
sure
an area of work that i was going to say
is that hard that oh it was incredible
i agree it's hard for me too incredibly
difficult so i spent a lot of time with
my family
trying to navigate different versions of
boundaries that i could put into place
that would prevent me from feeling like
i needed to
go no contact i was trying to find i was
going to say do you talk to your family
at all i do not so i was trying to find
a workable middle and
that i say would lasted over a year or
maybe a year and a half right
from the beginning where i started to
put in like peel back
putting in limits putting limits but
because again of their
really a mesh system look it's so much
more normal than i mean i feel like
growing up midwest and racing nascar and
like
this they were like on board with the
family living all together in the same
house for their whole
life so that was foreign to me but i was
still engulfed in this
environment of much more codependency
much more of this integrated repetitious
cycle
of wounds and traumas that get passed on
and on
and it is not normal that you don't talk
to your family
you're like what happened what's going
on but as i've expanded
and gone into new spaces and areas and
people
and thoughts and wow you
realize that it is not that uncommon and
look boundaries are boundaries and
usually the ones that
have the biggest problem with them or
are are can be the ones closest to us
and because you're you're showing them
what they need to work on they don't
have them themselves that's what i my
reminder to everyone who's
navigating putting up new boundaries in
relationships especially
in the relationships where you're
getting the kick back because kickback
happens
sure kickback happens for for a couple
reasons one you you already have a
dynamic that's
in place so you have a version of
expectations if i've known you for 10
years annika i'm used to how you show up
in this relationship
how you don't right so if on your 11 you
you do something different
i i heard someone use this analogy and i
loved it it's like you changed the dance
moves in the middle of the dance
right so you violated my expectation so
initially
it's gonna unfamiliar there comes that
word again i'm not going to be familiar
with why you're not coming when you
always come so what's going on here
that can evolve though into acceptance
there's also the path though where
the reaction i'm seeing from someone
else is based more in their lack of
awareness of boundaries if they don't so
i always suggest if anyone out there
listening is struggling or having a
negative pushback from someone in
particular
look at that from what you know of them
do they have boundaries in their life
and the answer probably is no
so they were never taught it they were
never observation
they just don't know so i spent a lot of
time trying to find a workable middle
because i didn't want to have to cut off
contact with my parents
my family my parents are older now i
mean my dad is going to be 82 my mom's
going to be 18. wow
yeah you're
i wanted to find a way i have a nephew
that's involved in the mix so
part of the living together a structural
difficulty with my family is they do
live together my mom my dad my sister
and my nephew are all under one roof
yeah there you go
so enough is not that far off the
midwestern retaliation right i
could i i i couldn't just go see my
sister my parents were there
right or i couldn't just sit with my
parents my sister was and like i said
they're together always so
a lot of legit but i tried i tried i
tried very hard because i did not want
to cut off that contact
but i finally got to the place where and
i didn't know
how long it was going to be i just knew
i needed to to have a little bit more
space and
they were allowing at this point because
then even if i tried not to respond to
them to put up my own version
of a boundary like oh i can't talk to
you on saturday then i would get the
frantic text of where are you or what
happened okay
so you had to ignore that so that would
have to be because that's also another
thing that happens like because
while you might set the boundary you
don't you know you're not talking to
them they might still reach out and that
can be
that carrot can be a little a dangling
hair can be
yeah that's what i mean boundaries is
setting the limit communicating the
limit
and then maintaining the limit and
that's on you not on the person
yeah so i had multiple instances of
those attempted violations and then i'd
ignore them and then i get told about it
so long story short i made the very
difficult decision to go no contact
not sure for how long i would go no
contact um
and that really once i got over the
initial like grieving of that
and like whoa what's going on this is a
lot for me it really freed me up
energetically
yeah and it really freed me up
energetically i think to go to a deeper
level
of healing for me but boundaries i still
am challenged
in all my relationships to maintain my
boundaries to say those hard difficult
no's
to say this doesn't work for me uh i'm
presented with multiple opportunities to
do that you know whether it's through
professional world so i practice my
boundaries
i still have work to do in terms of my
own ego work you know i still have that
ego that
wants to show up and tantrum or tell me
you know stories that aren't helpful
so i'm still you know kind of doing all
of that work to just and
what i think ego work is i observe that
it's there you know thank you for being
there
and then i show up in my conscious state
and i get to choose i'm the person who
chooses not my ego
and that's something i talk about too
because i think a lot of us
believe that we should be able to
strong-arm our ego away or that it
should just go away once i know it's
there and it's really about living
with the fact that there might be times
where these stories older stories are
coming up from my subconscious
but if i can show up as myself in that
moment as that consciousness that is me
i can choose what i do with that story
and i don't have to allow that
to determine the choice that i make next
so that's
that probably too will be a lifetime
journey there will always be a story
that
you know my little self wants to show up
and tell me is the case in any given
moment i'm challenged
very regularly professionally with that
you know as my platform grows
as i get all these amazing opportunities
that are presented to me there's a
very big ego tantrum that goes on in
those moments that doesn't want to show
up that wants me to stay small
so that's lifetime work of healing that
i think i'll always be doing
it's a lot of it it's just a journey
vulnerability and honesty is admirable
this is not something that a lot of
people are comfortable to talk about and
i really admire that i also admire this
new process that you've been doing for a
while with your followers
of future self-journaling that's so cool
please explain
future journaling because when i when i
saw it come up i was like man that's
brilliant that's awesome i'm so happy
yeah that's that's been a really cool
process so
is it a system first off is this
something that people can sign up for it
you have
yeah what do you have available
absolutely so i want more help i'll
explain what it is and those of you who
are interested if you hop on my
instagram that's the main hub where
everything is saved so the dot holistic
psychologist you'll see a link in the
link in the link tree and it might even
be
in my bio right now that you can sign up
for my email list right and then when
you sign up for my email list
there'll be a i think it's a three page
with two pages of
prompts that you can use each day so
journaling is something i developed as i
started to do
research and understand the beautiful
reality that our brain
is what we call neuroplastic which means
it can change
so if you think that you're kind of the
circuits are hardwired
they are not yeah and i create it so i
kind of took
that reality another beautiful aspect of
our brain
is it doesn't know the difference
between what is real air quotes as in
objective reality that can lay my eyes
upon and or
imagined so if i close my eyes and
imagine a scenario if i imagine i'm on
the beach right now
i might as well quite literally if my
body would change me
i would i might as well be on the beach
right if i imagine this is the
i don't know if you're familiar with
these these studies i think they're so
fascinating
um they do this a lot with um basketball
like like sports
and health people mentally rehearse yeah
you know free
uh shooting foul shots three froze and
their
their percentage increases
just because visualization they could be
laying on their couch visualizing it so
that's that
that that illustrates the fact that
they're laying down new pathways and
they're imagining
but they might as well not even be
imagining because they're working their
muscles in a sense like it's real
it's so fascinating so what journaling
is it really harnesses that so it's the
active so if you get my guide
the first page really just asks you to
give a thought
into an area of change that you want to
see happen in your life and that can be
anything
i mean i suggest starting with one so
listeners might be like oh i have 20
things i want to do
start with one one small belly promise
change is hard yeah so getting clear on
one area it's important to say that
it's really important and because i say
this too because you
you don't want to address five things at
once it's going to overload you it's
going to send you an overwhelm and it's
going to send you right back into those
familiar patterns and you don't want to
fail because that's not a that's not a
process that you want to um experience
because you don't want
it to not be a place that you can go to
for reliable
consistent growth yes and you don't want
to fail and i love that you pointed that
out danica because
most of us have spent a lifetime failing
i call it self-betrayal right back to
why i can't change
if i've watched myself intend to do some
whatever
eat healthier whatever it is if i
intended to do that for
however many years 20 years i'm pretty
down on myself by year 21. i don't
actually believe
that i can eat healthy because i have it
so if i put an expectation bar up that
means tomorrow i'm going to eat healthy
and never eat unhealthy again
i mean i might as well not bother yeah i
mean talk about disappointment i've
disappointed myself for how many years
and i'm gonna do it again so you wanna
set yourself up
to be even if it seems so s i mean i
have this i always talk about this
this story because i have a community
member her name is ally and she's
amazing
her journey of at this point complete
and utter transformation i mean she's
she's healing she's her she has ms and
she has her symptoms under physical so
she's physically healing
she's singing again she was at the point
where she almost couldn't use her voice
because her ms symptoms were so bad
she's significantly you know lost weight
not that weight is a symptom
you know a moniker of that we need to
decide if we're healthy or not
but she's being healthy she feels better
in her body that's the way i could work
that
she just has made an incredible chance
to start it with a glass of water
so no small promise is small it's too
small she started with a promise and i'm
gonna drink one glass of water
at some point during my day every day
wow she's built on that
that's crazy crazy i talk about it all
the times i'm so fascinated oh my god
one glass of water it's like smiling
once a day like that
that's all and she noticed herself do it
she didn't minimize herself doing it
and she continued to acknowledge each
and every moment she did that and the
changes that came along with that
before you knew what she was journaling
wow so what journaling is once you're
clear
so say it is i want to change this one
area so i want to be
so for me one of the big things i
started to journal about was being more
present in my body
i wanted to break my habit of
dissociation so every day
page two so those of you who get the
guide you'll see on page two there's
just daily prompts
that will take you through so if you
want to get a physical journal you can
print out the sheets right on their
physical journal
but the act of writing in the present
tense so if i am someone who's
present right so if i'm disassociated my
goal would be i want to be present in my
body
if every morning i write i do it in the
mornings every morning you do it anytime
during the day if every morning i write
i am present in my body
in that moment i've told my whole body
i'm present in my body because i already
am present in my body and my body is
registering as if that's
true so if you write in the present
tense you're using that
you know kind of real or imagine it
doesn't matter you're reaping also
mentally
rehearsing because if i say that daily
now i've at least fired once
the new a new affirmation about myself i
am past way
right what i've been told and heard from
people how not present i am for so long
and i now know myself i'm not present
so now i'm already firing up another
pathway no i am present
and then i set the intention to check in
with myself and my body and to use my
breath
as my point of attention to bring myself
into presence
so i write that intention as part of my
journaling that's part of you know how i
become present
i connect with my breath if i do that
every morning now i've already had my
mental rehearsal for the morning so
that's great i've got my mental workout
in
but calling that as an intention i said
that as my you know i was conscious when
i was writing i like see what i'm
writing
that helps set me up to do that through
my day because the caveat about
journaling is it's not magic
it's not a journal that i close and the
sparkles come out
and you bury it
yeah yeah and then i'm done it does the
work for me that's just a tool
so then that and it might not have been
every day right but if i
when as i began to do that consistently
enough i would find
through the day i noticed how not
conscious i was that was my star point
and that was a reminder oh nicole you're
you're not on earth right now so come
back to earth use that breath
come back into your body and then before
i knew it i was doing that one time a
day
i was doing that two times a day three
four or five so now i'm creating that
actual
change in my life so the journaling is a
tool
that helps us create that so would you
actually um
journal situations where you were
observing yourself being
so what i was doing was how does it go
past those two thoughts
so it's it's just it's the prompts it's
setting the intention every day
to do that thing journaling can be a
really individualized process though
i know people i've never been one to
just free journal
i've used it strategically when i was
exploring different themes in my life
and things like that
but you could so i have a membership
and as part of my membership i'm
experimenting with morning
intention setting and then evening
having
the members take a check-in about their
day
about the areas you know because the
points where they succeeded in keeping
their
intended promise and the areas where it
was a bit more difficult and then what
they could tweak
the next day so you can evolve sure this
is really just the when i put out things
they're they're all of the work i should
do put it this way
my my caveat always is it's so
individualized
yeah these are ideas these are concepts
these are
ways you could think about it but i so
strongly urge everyone to make it their
own
to adapt it so if you're out there and
you like the idea of journaling
intention but you also want to journal a
bit more free associatively
and think about you know that that part
of your life or
that struggle in your life or those
victories in your life you can add
anything to it and i say this
globally there's no manual so what
exactly because it can be intimidating
for people to not
and so having that permission whether it
be through journaling
or meditating or however it is to go one
minute one hour
one sentence a whole book i really don't
care just
this is a facilitation process to
achieve the things that you want to
achieve
yeah absolutely yeah and i think the
beauty in it is in the empowerment and
it is
actually the process of making it your
own because the whole
the whole conversation you and i are
having we're not actually connected
to our authentic self we're not being us
and in that
not only we're not connected a lot of us
don't trust ourselves because we haven't
spent much time being ourselves
sure so even this the most empowering
part of
adapting something is over time not
overnight
but rebuilding that trust that you
actually you can find your way through
this and it might not look like
the way your friend is doing this the
work but you're doing it and you're
trusting the way you're doing the work
because i get so many questions and i
get it people asking me
exactly how what are the one two three
write the directions down and i
can't because my direction for whatever
it is that we're talking about
might not be exactly what your direction
should be
for you so the beautiful part is
learning
sure to connect with yourself and
learning
your way through whatever it is the
heart and the healing
yeah that reduces failure yeah you
didn't not live up to something
yeah um so what would you consider
uh your greatest life lesson so far
that's a good question what is a
greatest thing so many
i mean i think that the greatest life
lesson is is that we all have it in us
everything that we need and i'm still
working
to fully connect with everything that is
in me so it's a lesson in progress
but i think coming from such a belief
set
system of limitation um my whole life i
told myself whether it was
genetically what i was gifted or not
gifted with or just the conditions of my
life
i had myself and the word in a box of
sort and i thought that was the box that
i was gonna
gonna live in there were just certain
things that were outside of my box that
would always be
outside of my box and i think the
greatest lesson that i'm evolving
through
and will always continue i think to
evolve through is that there's nothing
outside of the box
it's all in this box and it's just how
do i get back to it and access it and
show up in it in the world
and i think that's the journey of life
for most of us for all of us yeah what
is the purpose what do you think the
purpose of being here is then
yeah i think reconnecting with that self
and it's all about going back and you
want to say the cliche
thing but i think it's a beautiful back
home back home into you
you know we come in this state and then
things happen and life happens and we
beautifully adapt in all the ways that
we have to and i think you get to
possibly your dark night where all the
ways that you were being aren't serving
you or causing those
misalignments and possibly even scary
symptoms
and then you are gifted in that
breakdown with the ability
to peel it all back and to return to
that
that state and some people you know will
will be on this journey for a lifetime
some people
might not and this is where it gets
difficult with family and the isolation
and the
alignment you're saying the vibration
not everyone is going to
be on that journey agreed totally
and that's a hard realization so it's
making the space
for the people you know that are in
whatever version of relationship
with you that they are for them to be on
their journey even if it looks different
than yours but i think it's to return
back to ourselves
is the point that's hard i will modify
and let you know as that changes because
it should and it should and it should be
it should be
it should you should add be able to add
to it if i'd asked you five years ago
and five years ago before you know
before that
you would have had an answer for it and
then you can expand and add chapters
and that's the beautiful thing of life
so thank you for helping
walk us all home to ourselves to our
heart and to our truth which is so much
harder than you would think
so much harder so thank you of course
thank you thanks everybody for listening
to the pretty intense podcast today i
hope you enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button